a silent voice is a new anime film
that's currently in the middle of a
limited release it's shown at a few
theaters here in Cleveland and is now
starting to spread out amongst the
nation this film follows a young boy in
sixth grade who gets a new classmate a
young girl who's deaf who's very excited
to communicate with her classmates by
bringing in a notebook that they can
leave notes in and she can get to know
the students better and eventually she
becomes a target for this boy and he
bullies her every chance that he gets he
makes fun of the way she reads the fact
that she is unable to vocalize like
everyone else he even goes as far as to
yank her hearing aids out and throw them
around the class this eventually causes
the girl to leave this school cut to a
few years later and this boy is
traumatized by the way he treated this
girl he eventually became singled out to
be bullied as well because of his
actions towards this girl so now that
he's older he's trying to track her down
he's trying to learn sign language
properly so that he can communicate with
her and seek some kind of redemption
this movie's heart-wrenching it's
extremely difficult to watch sometimes
especially if you have been a victim of
this type of treatment in school this
movie is tough to watch it's very sad
sometimes but it does things differently
than other anime films this movie side
steps a lot of the melodrama
that some animes fall into and it just
focuses on youth and the struggle that
so many kids go through and in
particular a different viewpoint usually
movies or anime of this vein will follow
the bullied character and you feel
really terrible for them and you want to
see them achieve some kind of redemption
sure you definitely want this girl to be
happy but this movie makes the ballsy
attempt to follow the bully and you see
his evolution from a young kid who feels
perfectly fine tossing a deaf girl's
hearing aids around after school into a
man who's deeply traumatized by the pain
that he inflicted on others
because it came back on him once kids
saw how horrified this girl was at her
treatment they began to turn on this
boy and now all of a sudden he's the
enemy so he becomes even more reclusive
than this girl used to be he doesn't
even make eye contact with people
anymore and the animators made a really
strong creative choice to have everyone
in this guy's world have a blue X over
their faces and if he ever communicates
with one of them or feels as if
someone's trying to connect with him you
see that blue X peel away and suddenly
there's a person there because you're
watching somebody who no longer knows
how to communicate with anyone in fact
he really never did his only way of
communicating with people when he was
young was making fun of them and so now
as an adult he has to live a normal life
but he has no idea how to actually
communicate with people because either
he was never taught or he just never
bothered to learn what makes this film
so special is that usually with anime
romances you have two characters that
are perfectly okay with loving each
other but there's some sort of
circumstance that's keeping them apart
in this movie you have someone who does
have feelings for the other but they've
done such despicable things in the past
that they have no idea how to break that
barrier to get a normal friendship plus
one of the beautiful things about this
movie is the conversations they have
through sign language oftentimes it's
just these really sweet scenes that are
mostly silent with them signing back and
forth and you read so much in their eyes
and this is of course attributed to some
really excellent animation this is a
beautiful-looking movie and it's the
kind of movie that gives me hope similar
to your name and other things by Mamoru
Hosoda it gives me hope that Studio
Ghibli and their difficulties
financially it's not the end of great
anime films there are tons of filmmakers
out there who are going to make films
like this and your name that are going
to breach through the barrier and we're
gonna get into theaters here and it was
really nice to see this movie ask for
issues it's very long it's like 2 hours
and 10 minutes and there are sequences
looking back where you're like did that
really have to be in the film
conversations between side characters
that do little but let you know maybe
one or two things that are on their mind
but in the end it doesn't really have
that much weight or impact on this story
but beyond that I mean
I really like this movie I had a great
time with it it has interesting
characters that feel real a very
heartfelt story that not too many films
or anime tackle it also has an
interesting undercurrent of
possibilities if you explore this angle
involving reincarnation that is sort of
hinted at as a metaphor and you can also
look at the film in that perspective if
you like to analyze films on a deeper
level a silent voice has a lot going for
it I'm gonna give it an a- if this does
come to a theater near you I definitely
suggest checking it out especially if
you're an anime fan but even if you're
not this could be the type of film that
I could see someone who hasn't seen a
lot of anime actually appreciating so
guys I hope you like this new anime
background I've been working on it I
just want to say to the incredible
gentleman who sent me this spike Spiegel
and that cañedo from Akira you made my
day and do you have no idea how much you
made my day because at Comic Con I
specifically went to the booth that salt
that sells those figures looking for it
and they were completely sold out you
have no idea how happy I was when I
opened it so thank you so much it really
means a lot to me and as always guys
thank you so much for watching look
forward to more anime reviews and other
reviews coming very soon if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck my nice
[Music]